we've spoken about HS to a lot over the
last year or so you must be delighted I
was delighted action of course the Prime
Minister and the then Chancellor came up
on Tuesday to confirm the decision but
the key thing is it was the right
decision
I've always argued that and there was a
strong business case for doing it so I
always suspected that ultimately we'll
get to this point which of course is a
great investment for the West Midlands
you said you suspected that we'd get to
this point were you a little bit nervous
at one point oh yeah I want a straight
answer
I was nervous cuz quite rightly when the
Prime Minister won the leadership
election he said straightaway we've got
to have a review of this and in any
review there is risk but as you're
probably know I was a member of the
review panel so I was lucky enough to
see the business case and when I saw
that I thought eventually this will come
through but there's also the politics
the economics was quite clear actually
but the politics was also challenging so
I'm really pleased that an overall
conservative majority led to the prime
minister giving a decisive decision as
you said the politics was always
challenging one of your allies if you
like in Westminster were Sajid Javid a
chancellor who was a big supporter or
there HS - what do you make of the
reshuffle where he he lost his job he
quit well you're right his decisive
intervention I think two days before the
prime minister and he met around ages 2
was really good that he came out really
clearly wasn't playing games he just
said this is what I believe in various
so that was admirable behaviour
personally I'm very sorry to see him go
I would describe him as a good local MP
of course a West Midlands MPs of a
friend for many years and I'm sorry to
see him go in that respect coz he did a
lot of very good things from work around
homelessness when he was in housing
department work around the Windrush
piece of you remember when he took on in
the Home Office incredible how decisive
he was there but very clearly much as I
admire Sajid the government is bigger
than one individual and I'm sure that we
assume that will continue the mission of
the Treasury interesting to hear your
view so on Sajid Javid I mean there were
reports that he was someone who was
trying to rein in spending to impose
fiscal discipline at a time when others
around the Prime Minister
we came to concern on the spending tab
so you a bit worried about his departure
it's so no I'm not worried about his
departure I will miss him I had a huge
confidence in him but I've never
believed that the Treasury was depend
on one individual each I think that I
think there's a huge tendency this week
to over personalize all of this story
actually I think very simply two things
are going on the Prime Minister's come
in with a clear commitment to leveling
up he wants to invest in infrastructure
hs2 is the first thing I'm sure we'll
see other things at the budget and at
the same time the Treasury was doing its
job saying hang on a minute here we've
got to have absolute discipline in their
finances and that's what as a party
we've worked for for ten years and we're
not going to let that be jeopardized at
all this is your kind of opportunity
what would you like to see in the
upcoming budget so I guess the first
thing I must say as mayor of the West
Midlands is the things that we'd like to
see for our region so two things that
stand out there of course investment in
Regional Transport is critical now
there's a lot of work done about why did
not just firming them but Manchester
Leeds Liverpool all of those areas why
do they relatively underperform
economically compared to their sister
cities around the world and this piece
about the lack of connectivity quality
of transport in those cities is always
pointed out so we basically want the
same sort of connectivity as you enjoyed
London putting it very bluntly so let's
get on invest in our metro we've had
clear commitment from the government
that that will happen in the second
thing of course if for us particularly
it's been the wonderful progress we've
made around clearing up derelict
brownfield sites to build houses on
those areas we've doubled our rate of
house building in the West Midlands it
has an aided government support so those
are the two local things then we might
come to some things we need nationally
and that I probably highlight a whole
question about business rate reform and
of course I want to see a budget that
really gets behind the whole climate
change challenge as well there's a real
opportunity to show leadership in that
respect and we are of course leaving the
European Union know we're entering the
next phase if you like of our talks with
the EU those trade talks I'm keen to get
a sense of what you would like to see in
them because in December 2018
you wrote this of course issues like the
Irish border fishing rights and the
backstop are important but here in the
black country in Birmingham Soho and
Coventry free access to the European
market is
critical are you worried that in these
trade talks that free access to the
European market is going a little bit
down the list of priorities
I'm not worried but I am determined that
we make our case for that to be
delivered actually so the reason
probably should just explain that I said
that is if you look at the West Midlands
economy it's still the manufacturing
heart of the country leader in the
automotive sector obviously our lead
brand would be Jaguar Land Rover the
biggest manufacturer in Britain and the
way in which all of those manufacturing
companies as well in aerospace as well
the way in which they all work is there
Goods coming through from Europe in the
supply chain probably go back out to
Europe back again that's this with a
complex supply chain we've got now and
we have to have that tariff free and
delay free so that is what I hope we
will be achieving in the negotiations
which are going on now let me say tariff
free and delay free yes because if you
listen to what the government is saying
at the minute it feels as if sovereignty
the opportunity try diverge and
sovereignty over rules regulations laws
is being prioritized above the
frictionless trade that you described as
so I think the government Act you
understand this extremely well all I
will say we've had lots of really
significant ministers have around the
table particularly Michael Gove coming
up spending time with the automotive
industry I convened a round table for
him to come and discuss and I am very
confident that he understands as does
the Prime Minister exactly what is at
stake here so my role as the leader
representative of the West Midlands will
be to continue to make that case and I'm
actually determined we do come through
on this I mean they also say that they
will accept checks if necessary yes they
and that means delays and the big it
well that we wait to say about that
actually there are ways that this come
in a bear in mind a lot of product that
comes in to supply chains from outside
the EU already has checks and there are
not delays actually so I'm up for the
negotiation and it's quite right at the
beginning of this what are we now ten
months of negotiation that we've put
this is a really clear requirement on
the table and it's have the debate of
course so running for re-election to be
where Mary
West Midlands that election in May are
you looking forward Hank Boris Johnson
on your leaflets we've done a leaflet
across the region this sent last month
and his face is on the leaflet alongside
me because it's a very important point
my job is to encourage the prime
minister and all of his team to take the
decisions for the West Midlands
unfortunately I wish it wasn't like this
the big financial decisions are still
all taken in London I would true
devolution we would be taking more of
them ourselves but at the moment they're
taking London so my job is to lobby for
that investment and that's exactly why
I'm very proud to say I work with the
Prime Minister on taking those decisions
hs2 a very good example this week if you
had to sum up the pitch in a couple
sentences what would you say and the
pitches I think straight forward that
the West Midlands was an area that
perhaps didn't achieve all its potential
for 40 years we were perhaps the worst
performing area of the country but over
the last three years we've really
bounced back dramatically you've seen it
in jobs in housing in transport
investment so don't change but it's now
proving to win for our people